what's up guys we are back talking all
about Nintendo and all about eating all
about that good stuff with Andre meadows
Andre you've been at e3 a couple days
now this is day two yeah seeing some
stuff what's your game of the show
what's that what's your game of the show
my gaming shelf game of the show I'll
game of the show I'm sorry I'm trying
here you see my pop star yeah uh yeah I
mostly I'm mostly played Nintendo so far
I'm still checking out some stuff but
yeah I could say I'm really digging of
Star Fox zero and I'm I memorial fan
obviously but I just super mario maker
I'm just really excited I it doesn't
bring anything like new as far as
graphics maybe the table but just the
concept of people being able to have
this community to share all these levels
just really really really it's gonna be
awesome I just I can't wait to play
everyone's different levels see people
make levels I think it's just going to
create a really cool community online of
people doing that kind of stuff so and i
have to say i'm also you know even
though that's already happened with the
smash for the dlc I'm kind of interested
in seeing how Nintendo continues with
DLC because we've noticed with many
consoles usually get one smash for this
game you get one mario kart game or
whatever so I think it's gonna be
interesting to see them continuing of
franchise up by adding all this DLC
continuing to add carts or racers or
levels or cadena add fighters something
like that and sort of keeping a game
alive and it's nice because it's a
completed game and then you're getting
all this stuff and it's extras as
opposed to feeling like oh this should
have been in the game already yeah by
that I think it's a smart move that
they're doing me too I mean I actually
I'm a huge fan of Nintendo's DLC in the
way that they're doing it they're doing
a little things differently with smash
bros compared to mario kart with mario
kart they had the packs yeah announced
two different packs you can get both or
just that buy them separately yeah and
uh but Sebastian force is different
because you know they had announced
Mewtwo yes that he was coming and then
they released him with all the meat
fighter costumes and all that stuff yeah
and then they teased Lucas is coming but
then at the direct that just happened
they showed off Ryu and Roy yes
completely out of left field yeah
but they released them all these
different costumes there's like all
these like the tacking costumes the
Virtua Fighter and all the sudden it's
like this is what smash verse is about
you know it's just like little bits of
history everywhere yeah yeah but what
was weird to me is there's not like a
package like it wasn't a DLC path where
you can just what you can I i downloaded
yeah so you can buy them separately or
they actually have bundles like with the
costumes you get all the bundles at once
and it comes in a discount and with the
recent what you could get everything you
get real Lucas Roy and all the costumes
in one pack at the one package results 1
price tag yeah yeah cool cuz when i was
looking at it was like and when they
showed it in the direct they didn't make
that clear I don't ya it was very much
just like by the costumes for two
dollars yeah yeah there's a individual
what the hell you know i bought the
second wave of costumes i bought all of
them which is a number of them and i
think it was like nine dollars yeah for
all of them for both wii u and 3ds
enough yeah yeah is the fact that the
dlc you can get it for both systems in
the mic I love that there they said they
were gonna keep the two games parallel
and I love that they're still doing that
yeah every fighter on the Wii U is going
to be on the 3ds even though 3ds version
you know isn't everyone's favorite yeah
I soul I think it's great game it's okay
if you if you're on the go it's a me I'm
like I'm at home I'm gonna obviously
play exactly even if I have to you know
go to another room and take care of some
stuff I can still bring the gamepad with
me but but with someone they go you know
from the plane or anything that the 3d
s1 works just fine uh-huh yeah but i
think that the directed for smash bros
is a really good sign for the future of
nintendo dlc and they hit with mario
kart they announced the two packs and we
haven't heard anything since the fact
that we didn't hear about mario kart dlc
at the c3 kind of tells me that they
might be done with that and that might
be unfortunately I was it has two more
because I really loved how they do
you'll see worked we get the two sets of
new circuits like that's awesome you
know it's a substantial amount of game
play compared compared to what was
launched with mario kart 8 you know yeah
so seeing smash bros now they're
releasing these new characters these new
stages all this stuff in it they hinted
that there's gonna be more n64 levels
coming back like Mushroom Kingdom and a
hyrule castle and I liked it they didn't
put a date on that and they didn't say
when yeah
just said it's coming because that shows
there is more DLC and we still have the
the roster like the online voting voting
thing of yes Goku right but what's
awesome about that is I like that they
had you and didn't even make that big of
a deal of it being Ryu because I think a
lot of people were voting for him but
adding him this is the first new
character we got for DLC shows we're
getting new characters as DLC and also
that shows that the third parties are
totally open yeah yeah I mean even uh
even Microsoft had said that if they
were interested in banjo kazooie that
you know they could talk you know that
would be awesome yeah that would be cool
to have some cross politics I honestly
believe that isn't that should be a big
part in to no strategy going forward
yeah how can we work with third party
companies to bring those franchises back
in because they knew they do need
third-party support that's a very clear
thing but being able to incorporate
Nintendo into those third-party games or
to have their party characters show up
more in Nintendo games so it seems like
it's a thing of like where we're our own
counsel my own systems but we are open
to the other characters coming in I
think publishers would be Natalie
something that publishers would get
behind I mean having I mean seriously
having pac-man Megaman Ryu and Sonic all
in a game with Mario and all the
Nintendo characters I mean that's
something I never would have believed
exactly growing up and that it that's in
a reality today and I've made a video
about I just like I played as Ryu
fighting duck hunt yeah and were you had
a tanuki tail I like that's like a fan
fiction right yeah that's the thing
about smash I think that so special it
has been so special for so long even
without the the third party character
inclusion necessarily is that it's just
a game it's a fantastical kind of game
it's a yeah it's a game that's i want to
say strangely believable but it's like
you don't think twice that you know dee
dee dee's fighting because your pikachu
or whatever yeah something about that
makes sense but you brought something
interesting that i mentioned in your
opinion on kind of being an attentive
expert is you were they bring up third
party and third party support what what
what would you do if you were in charge
yeah i was raging let's assume an excess
let's just assume for argument sake NX
as a console or something like that yeah
how would you get the third parties back
because i think a lot of the third
parties probably feel pretty scorned at
this point not even frustrated but
just outright like not even interested
anymore so how do you how do you get
them back yeah that's a tough one
because I think a lot of it just has to
do with the technology it's like it it's
if it's easier to pour a game across
consoles you're gonna do it and from
having the gamepad and having to make
the changes based on that I think it is
difficult sometimes and also you know
sometimes the graphic limitations of
being able to take this game and being
able to go like okay I can port this
across the board I can port this to pc
or to playstation or xbox and then to
nintendo so you know i don't know if
it's something where maybe the to noni's
can be a little bit more hands-on with
the development with companies may be
you know are just a separate team that
works on that um but I feel like that it
would be kind of interesting to see if
they can work with third parties to
bring some good exclusive games that
people would be fascinated by an
interesting end and and put it on
Nintendo um not so much just direct
ports but that's also the problem with
the sales I mean like you know like Rain
Man was supposed to be a wii u exclusive
and then changes happened and things
like that and uh you know lego city
undercover which is a great game I do
want to play but they won't play it
because it's only one we you you know
and so I think that is a difficult place
that to be is how do you how do you get
the game particularly a third party game
that makes me go I gotta buy with you
just so I can play that yeah I mean you
know going back to every time I with an
ex like I don't think this is what it
would be but like what if NX is a
platform that would make it so that you
play Nintendo games on the other
consoles like that means in some way I
don't even know how that would work but
like it that would be very interesting
and that would solve the problem
nintendo has a better parties because
they just wouldn't need to worry about
it you know yeah make games I don't
think Nintendo is going to leave the
hardware or like console maybe they
might leave the hardware world but they
might not leave the console world I
don't know what that means well maybe to
me it's almost like maybe they leave the
whole console world but not the handheld
world since they're obviously still have
a viable handheld it's underpowered and
it doesn't matter right that we use
underpowered it actually matters
significantly because no one wants to
bring games to it because they won't
work even even with uh what what it
wasn't for the project cars that they
were talking about how it was running at
25 frames cars or one of the one of
those get one of those racing games
where they were like it's running at 23
frames a second on with you like we
can't get it to run yeah
and that's a frustrating thing like it
doesn't matter on three days because a
lot of games are made for 3ds yes right
and so that's a different thing but when
you're when you're an Activision and you
want your game everywhere and you don't
care you're totally agnostic yeah it's
like well we're not gonna we're not
going to go through this whole all this
trouble yeah the port you know the ps4
and xbox one which is simple for them
and then yeah so we would have the
country power it today it fits everybody
or is overpowered so much that you can't
go back exact that is we use biggest
fault is the fact that like it's not on
par with the other systems that was the
week's biggest fall to write you know
and the biggest success of it is that
the games that are made for it are only
on it and they're special but that you
don't get the call of duty's you don't
get the assassin's creed or at least not
like the right version so yeah and we
getting laid or something yeah you get
like the weird spin off which is funny
he's like you sexually are getting what
was last chance PSP version you know the
one that's like oh well here you go
here's the other prince of persia game
yeah i really want to play all right
let's it's it's upsetting that Nintendo
is in the position it's in but it's also
it's earned a position like they made
their choices and they saw the success
of the wii and i think they were kind of
like well we're good we're just gonna do
it again but i don't think anyone up
there really thought about well how are
we gonna do it again yeah here's a
gamepad we'll figure it out at some
point and here we are what three years
down the line and there still isn't the
game that's like that's why I need a wii
u gamepad you know that's why this
system needs to happen des proved it
within a year ya know that we proved it
I mean immediately immediately write
down but at least it had that here's why
you need it right yeah with the with the
game tied it's like splatoon is great
you know it's really fun but it's not
that game where you're like I need this
starfox awesome but all of us are like
just let me play yeah yeah like all a
lot of those games you like them but do
you really need the gamepad I mean like
even with smash they brought back it
made an adapter so you can play it with
the gamecube controller so yeah so i
don't know i mean it the thing about it
is that a lot of times is with the
weight into no makes their games
sometimes they don't need as strong of a
graphic capability for the stuff in
there making because they even have all
these different artistic styles they do
to the game I understand it why they
don't really get to our to that but you
know it would
be nice to have a call of duty and tomb
raider or any of these games on a wii u
cost because i like i like nintendo i
want to buy the nintendo version of a
game I used to when I when they had the
gamecube and all that said I bout the
game Qbert yeah and I'm that's the thing
is like yeah that generation there was
that option and a lot of people wouldn't
buy the game conversion yeah the xbox
for ps2 or what up for specific reasons
and I feel like Doc generation was so
fun because they were on par it was
weaker but it's like it wasn't
significantly weaker I guess what soul
calibur 2 came out which system did
everyone want yes so the soul yeah oh
yeah thank you exactly which I was not
what I was I was saying you know now
that we're getting street fighter 5 and
Ryu was in Smash Brothers it'd be pretty
interesting if they were able to sneak
in at endo character in the street
fighter 5 I would love that like low
voice exclusive yeah yeah which would be
totally interesting but I mean that's to
all your guys points I mean that's why I
don't read too deeply into wheeze 100
million sold because it's not so much I
mean in the immediacy of the financial
reality of it you want to make your
money you want to sell games and
hardware that's great but more it's more
about what hooked you yeah and clearly
the hook for we wasn't there right after
a while because we use sales or you know
sub 10 million so one tenth of that
after two and a half years on the market
so but I do feel bad for them in a sense
that it seems like they can't please
anyone with the gamepad specifically
because everyone's like we'll use the
gamepad use the gamepad they're like
what we did this isn't this right well
we don't want to use them like that no
Michael their dollies they're trying but
maybe what it shows is that the gamepad
was just an ill-conceived idea to begin
with but I think that's what it is it's
like when we say use the gamepad but
then at the same time well don't use in
the games we actually wanna play yeah I
think that is the correct statement
though it's like give me a new game I
don't know about give me a wii sports
yeah give me something that I'm not
looking forward I'm not I don't want it
in Zelda or Mario or Metroid or smash
bros I want it in this new experience
that I'm gonna get it and be like oh wow
you know des it had all of the the like
Professor Layton and all these things
that were like oh cool a new experience
here's something new that I'm doing with
the touch screen and all this stuff and
des was special because it I had the
games that aren't on the other Nintendo
consoles right so yeah and I think
that's the thing i mean i think as great
as I gamepad is I think that if you if
they even came off the bat wit here's
this new console and you can use your
your DS or 3ds as a controller and those
elements that we see on the gamepad are
part of that just that alone I think
would be something that people would get
behind because it's like we've already
got this one console now we could
connect it with the other and so you
know it would work that way yeah I feel
like if there was a way to get whatever
the next nintendo console is on to the
same level as the current consoles like
a ps4 and xbox one but again add that
element of nintendo with their first
party games add the elbe nintendo to
third-party games yeah like that will be
that will be think because everyone
knows that the majority of what people
like about the Tendo are those iconic
characters are this game playing
switches that you can only get from
Nintendo so only thing you need to do is
bring the third party into it have that
third party be at the same level and
then keep that Nintendo incorporated
into it and you're good to go and then
if you can have it where those even
merge from time to time I mean it's
really as it was having like it wasn't a
tekken tag tournament where you had a
minute like it just makes it different
yeah you know so I feel like that's
something that Nintendo could use to
their advantage they have these
characters that are exclusive to them
and they could use that to make the
gaming experience on Nintendo a
different experience than other consoles
if they can get the hardware to match it
yeah well let me ask you guys a question
as people who Nintendo has touched very
deeply like you know it is part of our
lives yeah a part of who we are oh yeah
would you if you had your ideal world
where you got to decide what happens
would you rather Nintendo bow out of the
console making you know like doing what
they're doing and just making games for
the other consoles or would you rather
then release the next console that is up
to par with the other systems I would
like up to fine i would feel i would be
very sad if the day ever came in the
tender said we're just going somewhere i
mean i was i was bummed would say get to
that you know just like that's an era
that is now done you know and before
sonic is just like on the street begging
for coin making four rings enough you
know it says so uh I i would love to
understood be in it but i don't know i
don't know if them
not being at the same level technically
that's our choice yeah you know if they
have the capability of doing it and
they're just not doing it or if they
literally did it do not have the
manpower to do some of that but yeah I I
would love to have the next gen Nintendo
right along the next gen playstation and
xbox and then like I said be able to add
that into no experience Yesi for me I
think I'm on the other side and I let me
to say because I I don't even want to
think of a world where Nintendo isn't a
video gaming system yeah but I think
that they don't need to have that
console for it to be what I want and
that's what I really need to admit to
myself is the fact that if they were to
just make games for the other guys yeah
I don't have to worry about all this
stuff I'd get more of what I want I
would get more good games they wouldn't
need to focus on all their divisions and
stuff working on consoles and hardware
in 3d ass and all this stuff they'd be
able to just make more mario metroid
starfox would get f0 and get these
smaller things because they'd have not
only more like resources to work with
making them but also more places to put
them on different levels like f-zero all
right maybe it's not going to make sense
as a commercial like retail game yes
what that on PSN could be great you
don't see them being like they're like a
steam basically could they be like a
Nintendo service where you can play
online well that's what I hope that is
why all yeah I hope that this happens
because it'd be really interesting and
then with them not having to worry about
the third parties and stuff because
that's just the thing I'm not giving the
people that choice they have to make
between do I get up do I buy xbox one
and invest or ps4 and invest yeah just
being like would intend oh we make games
and I think there's a key difference
between nintendo and sega like I love
Sega as a 90s kid so for this place in
my heart for sure yeah but at the end of
the day there hasn't been a bad Mario
game you know our house there hasn't I
mean I'll seriously thats been a bad
Metroid game there's been a bad that's
Roy be able to like all the red but it's
not bad right you know Zelda there
hasn't been a bad one so I think that
the Sega it has bad games oh yeah you
know and to say the great games there
there are of many of them but it's not
nintendo nintendo is a great great great
great great i also think that the
financial realities of sega at that time
they really
saturn and bomb they really couldn't
afford another failure and dreamcast as
much as you loved it wasn't failure was
a commercial failure came out too early
people were waiting for ps2 at that time
I mean I bought my dream cats but a lot
of people at that time didn't but I'm
kinda with you in the sense that
Nintendo was structurally built as a
hardware and a software company and I
respect that and they made great
hardware at one point in their history
and it wasn't necessarily about power it
was about the games yeah yeah and that's
the salient thing is that the games the
special sauce is not in the hardware it
never wasn't the hardware because we was
a great system but it proved it with a
game it improve it wasn't self-evident
so a year ago or even six months ago if
you were like Colin Nintendo is going to
make ps4 games now or my xbox one games
I bet you're out of your mind yeah
that's now with this DNA thing and all
this kind of stuff I'm like I don't
really think that that's that that's
that far-fetched anymore and I think
that if they want to make a mario game
and sell three million copies they put
it on Wii U right if they want to sell a
mario game for 15 or 20 million units
they would put it on ps4 and xbox one
yeah and that's and that's like and
that's you know yeah they would they
would if that happened and if they got
in bed with one of the one of the
console manufacturers which i think
would be actually xbox and not
PlayStation yeah because of the bad
blood that goes back to the early 90s
between sonia nintendo that that would
be mastered yeah now massive massive
stuff i think the final pillar that is
the reason that i would prefer nintendo
to leave the console game is the fact
that okay the special sauce is the games
yeah other special sauce Nintendo is the
creativity of doing something new you
know the gamepad or the motion controls
and all that stuff but what really it
would be awesome to see is PlayStation
and Xbox right now we have the hollow
hollow lens we have oculus we have move
we have all this stuff that really i
mean we're seeing cool things for but
it's like specifically with with
morpheus it's like all right where is
where's the thing that's going to make
this into something really tend open
come in there and oh could do that you
know and if the general didn't have to
worry about making a console and having
all these third parties to do it all
that and they could just worry about
making the system seller for Morpheus
making that something worth playing yeah
so maybe the happy medium is is that
it's it's something it's maybe like I
said like a steam think
service Nintendo basically takes their
console digitally you know and then you
can get all the games are there and then
whatever they like you might basically
like a nap and you can then play that on
PC you can play that on ps4 you can play
it on xbox one or whatever makes it
available so it's still Nintendo in its
self contained area so doing its own
thing you just now because it's digital
you have access to it on other platforms
including you know since they're going
mobile that's I feel is a possibility
exactly this leaves hey we're gonna make
ps4 games commence 11 games we're gonna
make our games we're still gonna make
them just now it being on this console
it's now on this digital app that you
can now put anywhere right now what's
really interesting about that and yes
this is something that is like would be
really crazy and people would have to
wrap their heads around but amiibo like
yeah there's potential there where it is
digital but if you want to buy that
physical good that console could be a
meebo yeah and if they could finally
figure out making that be be something
that's like substantial I'd like it was
the games I don't know if adults would
want to be buying all these toys or
stuff the general general would wanna
[ __ ] you know the millions out there
yeah the rest of the world not just the
hardcore I think that's the way I think
their next console should be in a meebo
it should be a giant shape to meebo and
everyone would buy it that would
definitely be attentive the way to win
the one thing that's certain when they
tend to write out of me and it happened
with the DNA announcement and happen
with all these things this is a company
as we said earlier that's finally
starting to change you know and they
realize that they must change because
there's a lot of chatter about all the
money they have in the bank some it
doesn't matter that money can disappear
in a few years if they don't start
selling lots of games again you know I
mean yeah and that's just the reality of
the situation oh yeah especially with
the rd going into hardware and all that
stuff I agree with you it's like it's
like an amazing dream to think that they
could take a pass just as powerful as
ps4 xbox one and put Mario on it you
know I mean and just don't worry about
the extraneous stuff to worry about the
hardware don't worry about selling
Hardware don't weigh about it make the
game yeah you guys they would take over
the world I really believe that they
would they would be the Nintendo that we
missed so much yeah I think it is I
think there is a significant level of
stubbornness and I don't necessarily
blame them yeah because I think they can
reclaim that old glory but the wii is
the anomalies I've said many times and
yes sold this sna is sold below that and
64 / sold below that gamecube so below
that now we use so below that that is
basically a trend with one anomaly they
need to they and the same thing with
their handhelds with the exception at
yes which is the anomaly than 3d s
obviously really struggled with it I
just slash the price significantly so
yeah I feel like and I know a lot of the
tunnel fans get mad at me I have the
iron draw the eye of round in 10 depends
you know but I'm just talking as it
laughs then Tilda fan that would love
nothing more than for that company to
destroy everyone again yeah I do believe
it big it is as a publisher of games you
know yeah me too i think i do think that
in addition to publisher games it is
helping create and form the hardware
with the other guys you have their
resources and their money and the
creativity and brains of nintendo and
just the games on it like that could be
all like just thinking about it gets me
so excited ya know that I you know the
going down to the summer it is i think
that is something that is gonna have to
see if that could happen you know will
nintendo be open to other couples well
the other companies be open to work in a
nintendo after after certain things have
happened so yeah I and ideal well I
think that would be great i mean i don't
worry i would like for all the book to
work together because i feel like the
whole console separation gets a little
crazy from time to time but yeah it's
just they I just don't ever want to see
that brand go away i think that's it I
think that's what we're kind of thing
here is that whether it's another
console whether it's you know going
through other consoles or or having a
separate a person like that here's what
that brand today and that's that is
little concern is if they go or route
where it's still not working and it
starts to go down a vision the brand
eyes out Mario can be a great icon but
if the consulate its own is not selling
it's still gonna be that less and less
people over the course the top or not
playing those games not having that
relevance to them yeah like we have
advertisement against a guy is a perfect
example of that you know a guy signing
is it is not gone yeah but it almost is
so I say make boom out of everything
Mario boom Zelda move Metroid boo boo I
want to ask you this question is
something that Tim and I talked about
sometimes kind of be more kind of funny
its kind of Resident you know resident
Nintendo kind of people aren't specially
time obviously what dorman IP would you
want to see come back or what IP would
you want to see Nintendo kind of do
something because i often think about to
IP myself that I've eyes have been
dormant for
time one is star topics which I think
that they could do something clever with
but the other one that I'm actually
really interested in people make fun of
me for this is ice climbers I felt oh
yeah a triple-a open-world 3d platformer
we saw yeah yeah we just got out of
Microsoft's thing that's your meeting oh
yeah yeah look what he's like a brother
like that Larry crop balloon fight
before duck hunts obviously bend or my
mean there's just all these random idea
littering the historical a Nintendo yeah
what do you what would you want to see
come back I really honestly would love
to see a nice next-gen def 0 I think
that that I mean the mario kart is great
i love it i love it they even
incorporated some effort 0 there well
captain falcon needs to lisa ride again
and i just think i just really good
evidence I thought if i'm not mistaken i
I saw some game that was like I kind of
looks like f-zero but it wasn't that
they were doing but uh yeah I really I
really would love to see a nice good
quality of 0 I haven't they released it
up 0 game so game keep was the last one
right maybe was the last one yeah well I
think there was an arcade one after that
but yeah that was our game there must be
a reason in the reason I probably it's
the same thing we would talk about
Metroid where everyone's like why is it
retro working on metro my cuz Metroid
sold like less than 10 million units in
taught in its entire history yeah that's
why I get about that yeah thing like to
ask you a question about what doorman
franchise to wanna see back I think f0
is a good answer but i'ma throw twist in
there I don't want the racing i mean i
do i do want that but what I want to see
is a captain falcon game oh I would like
maybe like a third person action game
yeah a lot of horse racing elements in
it yeah well yeah yeah exactly it if
there was racing but there also was like
more like a third-person action yeah cuz
antenna was kind of lacking that that
kind of just like what a lot of people
know captain falcon from smash now you
know like a younger generation so if you
can sort of incorporate his fighting
style as well as the racing into a night
that could be a very interesting yeah
yeah yeah I know and I would love to
play a step especially the captain
factor we have now yeah I would totally
be down for that uh-huh I like it
catafalque in the game oh good well good
for me my other answer starfox and it's
here yeah finally you know I decided to
look at this game and be like this is
finally a real Starbuck starfox because
the last one that I I really loved what
star fox assault not a great game yeah
gamecube but they had element
and like I love the story i love that it
starfox has always been the star wars of
the nintendo universe it's always kind
of been the thing that had it had a
story had a universe that has never
really been seen that much like it yeah
its way to detail for the fact that it's
a on rail shooter you know the whole
backstory of fox's dad and like pigma be
betraying them and all this stuff it's
like you find out so much about these
characters just flying just from the
little words popping up you know yeah an
assault kind of took it a step further
with fleshing it out and like creating
that world a bit more and to come back
to it like from what I've seen I'm like
they're expanding on that thank you
there's no on foot missions yeah yes and
they use voices that's always nice
intellect those words you know I know
you were waiting for starfox adventures
too so I'm sorry that was specific no I
mean I don't hit on starfox adventures
cuz it is awesome like I love it that
games very special to me but my favorite
part of it was the the air mission yes
you know and they're very limited the
final boss was Aaron dross you know oh
yeah it wasn't on a narrow mission so
absolutely I'm definitely waiting for
some more of that one uh another
question I'd like to ask me we've talked
about this hypothetical I want to still
do this in a full flesh kind of way I
kind of funny yeah I want to do kind of
like a publisher draft with all the
developers or like what publishers make
sense in the first parties for all of
them for instance sony has to racing
developers they probably don't need to
racing developers yeah what developer
out there that you see making games
outside of Nintendo's ecosystem do you
think would make sense for Nintendo it's
great with ya in other words in other
words in a total fantastical kind of
thing if the Tendo could go like we want
to buy this developer oh yeah well I've
I've said it since smash I think
Nintendo needs to get sonic from Sega
they need to get mega man from Capcom
need to bring them into the family make
them disses cousins and let's see what
they would do with those properties
because I there's some love that needs
to be made for those those characters
and I feel like Nintendo having that
retro that retro nostalgia with them and
knowing how I kind of those characters
are kid do something really great with
them yeah you know I never thought of a
Nintendo sonica yeah how to fix sonic
give it to Nintendo yeah exactly how to
fix sonic quixotic away forever know how
you pick no definitely not
got on us we'll figure out the sony the
same way it was like he's like we've
been around for so long you know why yes
I was good sometimes i wake up from
nightmares and overnight unlike sonic
bus live laundry thank you so much bye
ladies and gentlemen we're kicking off
to chloe dykstra and nick Scarpino stay
tuned